come on man you say you putting a hula
dog you actually week right now just
brain freeze come on ain't no brain
freeze don't make you yell like that man
hit your head with the brain freeze come
on in it you're going silver balls on it
okay Exorcist what are you doing now
well you doing some kungfu over they
can't be doing this much to you
listen man it'll be a punk-ass [ __ ] man
get over the brick wait you're afraid
now you see anything you're just scared
brain freeze make you scared
on this mom know what man
you weak man you a weak ass that's the
problem hold up now hold up now hold up
now hold up now me respect you now into
the brain freeze this is straight crazy
minutes quiz the time man that strangle
Benny with my bare hands
cuz he didn't have my money all right we
got him go
what stand up slowly latest not know
you're just sixth grade you under arrest
for the murder of benny tech there are
tricks get him out of here you punk ass
brain freeze mother you going to jail
for a long time I'm in too deep
ah I got a brain freeze brain freeze yep
you